ええーもうすでに、ニュース
とかで、見てる方がいると思いますが、
１２月２５日の
朝４時くらい、自宅にストーカーの人が
侵入してきました。
こわい。　　　　怖いよー　助けて(はじめん心の声)
あ、Twitter読もうっと。
ごめんなさい。
最近ちょっと、Twitterさぼってたなぁ　あ、ウーパールーパーから来てますね
ありがとうございます。　一応、
大丈夫でした。なんかすごい、Twitterとかで、
大丈夫？っていう、メッセージをたくさんいただいたんで、
とりあえずまあ大丈夫ですよって
いうことも、お伝えしたいところで、あるのと、
こういうことがあったと、皆さんにお伝えしたいのもありますし、
もし、ストーカーの被害って結構おおいみたいで、
こういうことがひょっとしたら皆さんの身に起きない
ということも、０ではないので
一応皆さんにお伝えしようと思っております
とりあえず、
元気です！全然元気なんですけども、
久しぶりに、
「うわー動けねぇなー、これ」ってくらい、
固まっちゃったりしたんで
まぁ、今は全然余裕なんですけどね
マジで知らない人が、家の中に入ってきたときは、
うわぁ、マジで何も出来ねぇなって思って
まあ事件があった25日僕後輩と一緒に部屋に居たんで
なんとかできたんですけど
多分一人だったら固まって通報とかそういうことも
できないんじゃないかなっていうぐらい
非常に怖い思いをしてしまいました
ま、一回こう、入られてしまって
説得ってわけじゃないんですけど「一回外出てもらってもいいですか」ってなだめると
出てもらえたんでその瞬間すぐ
鍵かけて速攻110番したっていう流れです
鍵！ちょっと見てもらっていいすか？
ﾄﾞﾀﾊﾞﾀﾄﾞﾀﾊﾞﾀ
どうするどうする？
する？する？マジでどうする？
だって…
１１０だよねー
１１０っすよね
あんだけ言われても入ってきたんですから
勝手に。
失礼します
「家の中まで侵入されちゃってー」
でもなんか今無理やり追い返したんですけどー
はい
えと、24です
や、まったくしらないっすね
いや、でも、なんか、ホント、自然に不法侵入されて・・・
あっ今パトカー見つけましたこれってもう即逮捕ですよね？
めっちゃ対応早い(ﾟ∀ﾟ)
で、来てもらって、速攻現行犯逮捕されてたんですけど、
以前動画で、言っていた、「ストーカー被害にあいました」っていう
動画で、禁止命令っていう、
もぅ、僕の近くによったら近くによった瞬間
即逮捕
ていう状況下のなかで犯人の方が近づいてきたので、
もう迷いなく速攻で110番で逮捕してもらったんですけど
いや、、、
怖いっすよ。怖いというか、僕が話したいのは、その後の話なんすよ
人を逮捕するのってすごい手順を
組まないといけないみたいで
事件があったのがだいたい4時くらい、
で、そっから警察の方が来て取調べとかいろいろしてだいたい朝の5時半、
そっから僕事情聴取があったので警察署に行って
被害届を出さなきゃいけなかったんで
こういろいろ手続きとかお話したりこうなんか書いたりやったりして
気づいたら12月25日のお昼になりました
俺のクリスマスはどこ行った・・・
僕のクリスマスほぼ警察署ですからね
なんか、事件が起きちゃって、
誰か逮捕するって、そのぐらい時間が
かかるんだな
ってことを、僕は、すごい、感じました
今回。
結局クリスマスの日、僕、朝から
警察署連れてかれて
お昼まで一睡もせずずっと取り調べしてたんすよ
本当に、心配してくださる方が
たくさんいたんですけれども
無事捕まって良かったと、思っております
ぼくんち防犯カメラも仕掛けてあるんで
結構思ったよりスムーズに証拠とか出たんですけど、
まぁ、でもこうゆう事件がおきてしまうと
でもすっげえ時間持ってかれて、
嫌な思いももしたし怖い思いをしたな
っていう話でございます
実際ですね、ホントに知らない人が部屋の中に入ってくると
まじで動けないですから
僕後輩と二人でポケモンしてたんですけど
ほんっとに10秒ぐらいマジで全く動けなくて
恐怖で。
誰かと一緒にいれて、本当に良かったと思います
皆さん、ストーカー行為には気を付けましょう！
バイバイ(@^^)/~~~
バイバーイ（電話）
てつやも気をつけなよ
ED